I know what will happen Sunday here at
the Super Bowl and that is Lady Gaga
will put on a spectacular halftime show
you know we have been coming to the
Super Bowl for nearly a quarter century
and covering the biggest names who have
rocked the big game how excited are you
to be doing Super Bowl it's amazingly
overwhelming et was with Katy Perry who
had the most-watched halftime show ever
118 plus million viewers in 2015 four
million more than watched the actual
game Beyonce in 2013 set the record for
tweets 268 thousand per minute it feels
good to know that the hard work paid off
the biggest show in America and there's
so many things that could happen it's an
epic spectacle and some of music's
biggest names have taken center stage
[Applause]
amazing is America's football
Oh how was it great loved it great crowd
lady been incredible really an
adrenaline rush but incredibly for the
first twenty four years the halftime
show was mainly marching bands and the
review up with people but when competing
Network started counter-programming the
game the halftime show shifted to a list
pop stars it was Michael Jackson in 93
in 2001 Britney Spears took the stage
along with her then-boyfriend Justin
Timberlake two weeks ago they called me
up and asked me and I was like yes
starting in 2005 the network went to
classic rock like the Stones the WHO and
Paul McCartney I see that you're wearing
red and blue today does that mean you're
rooting for the Patriots uh no this is
really it is just swung on honey
in 2011 the black eyed peas were lowered
from the root in Arlington Texas Lady
gaga take note headlining in 2014
Bruno Mars sat in on drums at one point
said that drum solo feel bro Bruno was
back last year joining Beyonce in her
third appearance and Coldplay in their
first do you top this feeling I don't
think it's possible
now halftime performers don't get paid
but of course their expenses are covered
and they do see benefits in other ways
for instance Cole plays record sales
jump three hundred and sixty five
percent last year after their
performance Beyonce and Bruno Mars also
uh saw a spike in their record sales so
a Monday morning get ready for a run on
Gaga music we'll be back with more in a
moment
you